I'm gonna be completely honest with you
it is July and this is not the Batman
movie I want to be talking about right
now but I am a giver you guys wanted
this so let's do this Batman Forever and
little did they know by forever they
really meant one more movie and then the
franchise is dead until further notice
so this is the first Batman movie where
Tim Burton was like I'm done with this
if I handed it to Joel Schumacher and
Joel Schumacher can do really good
movies you know Lost Boys a time to kill
even phone booth I enjoyed that movie
the dude can do good stuff and in Batman
Forever did a very subjective thing
really it's all about what you like so
we have Val Kilmer in this movie as
Batman and Bruce Wayne which I really
didn't hate him is Bruce Wayne to tell
you the truth I can buy the fact that
he's some 30 something year old
billionaire as for Batman he had these
really cheesy lines you know the color
right chicks dig the car really chicks
dig like I really he didn't feel like he
was the Dark Knight a lion was kind of
funny because his car was kind of badass
even though it was not the Batmobile a
bunch of blue neon lights shining in the
dark don't really scream hey
inconspicuous no one knows I'm coming
and even in the intro of this movie you
see the name's going buying you're like
this is completely different music in
this movie isn't as epic and then he
gets down there and everyone it's all
cheesy man they're all pointing up like
Batman there's a bunch of spotlights
everywhere and you're like this is a
completely different franchise I'm
convinced of it now it's just a totally
different direction they wanted to go I
get a directors gonna have his own take
on it but this is a completely different
world the entire dark and mature tone
that Tim Burton built up for everyone's
completely destroyed it's no longer for
adults they're doing it for you know
kids now then again this movie has a
couple of mature jokes in it so you're
like well maybe it's not all for kids
maybe they think adults like this
so let's get on to the villains in this
movie the main villain in Batman Forever
is Tommy Lee Jones as two-face they
marketed the main villain as the Riddler
because Jim Carrey plays the Riddler and
Batman Forever
everyone was head-over-heels for Jim
Carrey so they're like just put him in
all the ads we're going to make him look
like the main villain which in terms of
corporate douchebaggery movie promotion
that makes sense so like we need to get
people in the seats people will go if
Jim carries the Riddler doesn't change
the fact that it was a complete
bait-and-switch and they lied to us all
and Tommy Lee Jones is two-face I
couldn't stay I couldn't stand Tommy Lee
Jones is two-faced for the same reason I
really didn't like Jim Carrey's Riddler
in this movie because they were both
the Joker someone somewhere probably
Joel Schumacher had this idea that all
villains have to be just crazy an out of
their mind and really animated people so
Tommy Lee Junction says reg is weird and
so is Jim Carrey he's all eccentric also
he's Jim Carrey you knew he was gonna be
like that which for the Riddler kind of
works it's not a completely inaccurate
representation in terms of Riddler
representations there is a really crazy
animated version of the Riddler or you
have the really methodical Riddler you
know like the one in Batman the Animated
Series I love that Riddler
in fact I've wanted to see a Riddler
like that in the movies I just haven't
yet but the two-face thing there's no
real excuse for it there are a few
directions you can go with Harvey
two-face Batman the Animated Series
again represented in very well that's
what I expected going into this movie
not the Joker with half his face burn I
just felt like the villains in this
movie were really cheap and they took no
time to put together they're like yeah I
just didn't be crazy whatever I mean
Tommy Lee Jones in a serious villain
role would be really good he would be
good for two-face back then just not the
two-faced that he apparently represented
in Batman Forever and then you have
Robin in this movie because you knew
they were going to introduce Robin at
some point in this franchise and they
did now I think it's kind of funny that
in Batman Forever Commissioner Gordon's
like Oh his family died Bruce Wayne can
you take him makes sense it's can you
take him what he's not a legal adult he
has a crash with someone no I are you
saying that he's a 16 year old because
he's not he's he's a 35 year old man
looks it anyway just the whole thing
didn't make any sense it was like they
were like all right we need to find a
way to put Robin in we're gonna hand
them off to Bruce Wayne because Bruce
Wayne's Batman dude I mean by no thought
really being put into this movie or its
characters oh and Batman's love interest
you can't forget about Nicole Kidman cuz
you know why would you want to other
than every reason you want to it's not
that Nicole Kidman is a bad actress or
anything like that I'm not gonna say
that about her I'm just saying she
didn't make any sense in this movie and
she annoyed the out of me because
she's some shrink that Bruce Wayne has a
crush on at a point he's like I've never
been in love before Alfred what Batman
did you sleep through the other two
movies that you've been and you were
pretty head-over-heels over those chicks
and you interacted with those chicks a
lot more than you have this one I don't
think you're in love with her you're
just doing the fourteen-year-old boy
thing thinking you're in love with her
when you really want to bang her that's
it that's as deep as it goes you're not
in love with her at all
and she will probably not be in the
sequel just like the other two chicks
yeah she's not and the costumes are
in this movie not just you know the
Batsuit in the Robin suit balls but you
have to joke about the bat nipples
because it's just absurd but to tell you
the truth is
like the thing that's holding this movie
back if there were no back nipples it's
not like I'd be like oh well okay then
Batman Forever is just awesome the fact
that the Batman and Robin suits have
nipples on I was like the fourth or
fifth thing that's wrong with this movie
but not like the Riddler's outfit he's
wearing like from neck to toe tights
he's wearing like Riddler pajamas that
you would find at Walmart but not
supposed to be his Riddler outfit come
on give the guy a suit make him look
like an awesome Riddler not a gymnast
with a bunch of question marks around
his body I think it's kind of funny that
when you watch the special features in
the interviews about this movie Joel
Schumacher was talking about he had a
segment where it shows Bruce Wayne's
past because Bruce Wayne does deal with
this passion in this movie he's thinking
about when his parents died and I guess
he's the one who wanted to go to the
theater but his parents didn't want to
but he really insisted so they did and
so ultimately he feels like he killed
his parents because he's the one who
wanted to go that is probably the most
interesting thing that you could put in
this movie but they cut it for time all
right of all the things that you could
cut for time that's the dumbest thing to
cut because it kind of makes this movie
interesting the movie had Bruce Wayne
dealing with the repressed memories of
his parents death it had Robin currently
dealing with the death of his parents
this movie could have been really
awesome they could have related to each
other he could have seen Robin become a
hero being built from the ground up
Bruce Wayne training him but no they got
this bizarre cartoon that doesn't make
any sense it's actually worse than the
actual Batman cartoon which was actually
good you want to say they gave it a shot
just wanted to go in a different
direction that didn't work but at least
they kind of thought they were giving it
a shot in the end I will say Batman
Forever might be a good time if you're
drunk yeah now is a party those riddles
are really easy to solve though that's I
could solve them and I'm drunk and
there's not a thing the riddles in this
movie totally easy to solve Bruce Wayne
and alfred sit down for about two
minutes and crack the Riddler's entire
code yeah i was really on the edge of my
seat for that so Batman forever did
you enjoy it a lot of people are kind of
cool which I can't see it it was the
beginning of the end for me Batman was
digging his grave and my god the next
movie really closed the lid on that
in any case Batman Forever did you like
it comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you